Pavia Illinois I got a bit of bad news
here unfortunately I have to reschedule
this weekend it's something I'm just
finding out about now but I got to have
another back procedure so got to miss
this weekend but we have already
rescheduled the dates so Friday April
26th and Saturday April 27th I will be
back in bavia Illinois to do the shows
and uh your tickets will be honored so
make sure you come out and see me in
April 26th 27th bavia San Francisco I'll
be back Friday December 8th and Saturday
December 9th at cobs Comedy Club it's
the last stop of the live and Alive tour
for 2023 get your tickets at Ryan
sickler
docomo Lefty sun is now available as an
audio album go check it out everywhere
you get music I'm very excited to
announce that the Honeydew video is now
available on Spotify it doesn't change
anything for you at all it's just an
additional place to watch the Honeydew
go check out the Honeydew audio and
video now available on
Spotify the Honeydew with Ryan
[Music]
[Applause]
sichler
welcome back to the Honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
Studios I'm Ryan sickler Ryan sikler
docomond on all your social media and I
want to start this show like I start all
of them by saying thank you thank you
very much for watching this show thank
you for supporting these guests these
people come on tell you some of the
ugliest [__] in their lives so I
appreciate you guys watching Please
Subscribe um if you got to have more
then I am telling you you got to check
out the p patreon it's called the
Honeydew with y'all and it's this show
with yall and it is the wildest show I'm
telling you it's right now it's five
bucks that's it there's no tiar no
nothing it's five bucks there's hundreds
of episodes we got a best of a third
best of coming up with Josh Wolf and the
the we've done three like I said those
three episodes of The Best of we've done
like 10 to 12 on each those 30 plus
worth your $5 worth your Starbucks
coffee this week I promise you don't
just get that month you get of them all
right you get the Honeydew a day early
you're getting it ad free and you're
getting it at no additional cost and if
you're looking for a new podcast to
listen to I'm telling you my old podcast
the crab Feast this year we put it on a
new RSS feed I got it back and
that that Community it did over 1.1
million downloads this year that Library
it's insane and it's been dead for five
years that's how live it is all right go
check it out subscribe and come see me
on tour all tickets for my shows are
ransler all right now you know what
we're doing over here I always say these
are the stories behind the storytellers
we're going to highlight the little
lights all right today I'm very excited
to have this guest on please welcome
Britney Schmidt welcome to the Honeydew
Britney hello thank you for having me
you're very welcome it's kind of long
overdue to be honest yeah um thank you
for being here of course and before we
get into whatever we're going to get
into please plug promote everything and
anything Britney Schmidt please okay so
I am finishing up a tour right now I
have five weeks left all of the tour
dates are on Britney schmit.com which is
Britney BR TT n y Schmid s c hm TT no D
I took all of those in
college people always put a D in my last
name and I'm like they're all inside of
me
so uh and then I'm you erased the D out
of that name girl good for you College
you did it early I did it early
uh yeah then Britney Schmidt on
Instagram and Tik Tok you say dick tock
tick Tok yes it is it's a new platform
we're demonetized already so um well
again thank you for being here I I I
said to I was telling Kirsten I was
telling Brandy like I know you but I
don't know you it's a lot of that in
comedy but we had a great conversation
at The Improv on Theo show I mean
memorable that's why I'm saying oh she
was so nice she was cool I didn't really
know who you were before that like never
seen you at shows and things yeah it's
funny how long you can do be doing
comedy and you still meet new people all
the time yeah that have been around
forever so I want to get to know you
better and I know you've got some
stories I do follow you so I know that
you also talk personally about your life
in your standup um so I know you got
some stuff out there yeah but um please
tell me first of all where where are you
from so I was born and raised in
Wisconsin oh Wisconsin Wisconsin I'm
thinking I don't know why I had
Louisiana in my head but well what an
insult wow probably cuz I'm friends with
Theo you probably think we're like
siblings maybe I put that in uh no I
have been fighting hard to get rid of my
Wisconsin accent but it comes out every
once in a while like I can't say the
word Bagel how do you say it Bagel
because Wisconsin nightes say bag
they're like Bagel so they go hard on
the they go hard on the a so I say bagel
and sometimes it sounds like Boggle like
people are like what the [__] was that
word cuz you don't you ref to
say that's why yeah what else like what
do horses eat that's too easy that's
just nothing after that that was a
terrible example
right oh my God no you say nasal how do
you say nasal nasal no see I've worked
really hard to get rid of it but the
thing is I've worked so hard to get rid
of it that I thought I never had it and
I had a friend send me a video of my
last day of Senior High School recently
senior senior year in high school and I
almost threw my phone I was like who is
that girl I was like oh my God I got an
A in stats class like the teacher must
love horrible and you don't remember
sound like that yeah I people still to
this day are like where are you from you
have an accident I'm like I I don't hear
it at all when I moved here I [__]
thought I sounded like everyone right I
had a friend and so where we're from
Maryland other parts of the country too
but we put an r in wash mhm washer and
dry
Washington DC you know we're we're going
to Washington DC and I had a friend out
here one time goes what the [__] are you
saying yeah and I was like Washington he
go not Wasington he goes spell it and I
go w a s h i n g t o n he goes where's
the r and I go what do you mean there is
no R exactly he goes say it again I went
Washington and I was like listen it took
30 years yeah 30 years for me to be like
holy [__] I'm putting an r in there for
no goddamn reason and I I [__] yeah I
took all the RS you got the be got
you're from Maryland mhm see your accent
is very comforting to me but it gives
Southern Maryland people say I have
that's why I'm say you say the A's ours
too we draw our O's and our A's we say
phone right and road right and home and
then in California we're just perfect
yeah yeah no they got an accent out here
do you think so I do there's accent
where a little bit of that and then you
got valley girl too but also there's
this hard R here they'll be get over
here oh you know what I mean clean it up
over here and I'm like why you going
here all that
hard like hard we're going there already
okay well all right so you're from
wiconsin yes Mom Dad also like everybody
from Wisconsin like growing up there and
everything yeah yeah Mom and Dad are
both from Wisconsin neither of them ever
left well my mom gone now but she left
she left she left uh well she's dead she
didn't leave yeah she's just I got I
felt was that an ear you were just about
doing over there I don't know I don't
know where she yeah she isn't an ear is
she yeah well actually funnily she's in
my it's funnny a word I don't know but I
I followed it I knew what you were going
for have to look it up I would try it
and scrab I know that you're going to
have to challenge you're going to have
to challenge you're going to have to
challenge okay I think we're going
need get the official one get the
official one funny enough she wanted to
be spread out her Ashes to be spread out
in a forest and my sister was in charge
of this and my sister was wearing my
dad's hunting coat and she just fumbled
the ashes and they went into his pocket
and I was like well looks like she's
going to be spread at the dry
clean her ashes went
all and she just was like to shaking and
Ja just walking back to the car letting
the wind blow like the last place the
last place she would have wanted to be
is my dad's
hunting stuffed in [__] old ass
pocket listen it's so funny you say that
Britney cuz I [__] put in my I have a
living will and trust and I made this
lady this lady obviously know who the
[__] I am I'm like listen you need to
put this in there and she's like okay
okay and I was like I want my ashes
sprinkled in the Chesapeake Bay where I
used to go crab and fish with my father
I want her wherever she is I want her to
go do that like that's the LA it's our
last trip together father daughter right
right which is and the lady's looking at
me like you're [__] insane I'm like
put it in there so she puts it in there
in there and then I go home and I think
about it and it's exactly what I think I
think like maybe she's with her husband
and kids it's pouring down rain it's
muddy everywhere the [__] jar hits
It's spraying all over the Rainy Highway
and they're like sorry it just blows
back they wet it's like they dogs
licking it and [__] I'm like oh God yeah
it doesn't matter what you [__] want
what the world wants is what the world's
getting yeah but isn't it funny how
Petty you can be in a will they really
give you room to be Petty in those I had
to do one with my ex-husband when we
bought a house and we like they're like
who do you want give me an example cuz I
don't really I just have my daughter so
I just put that to her at this time yeah
yeah no it's like who do you want at the
funeral who do you not want at the
funeral well there's a not want at the
funeral list there's another allow and
I'm like oh we got [__] on I
want to know
what year that was implemented after
like all right we got to put a non non
invite there a not invite it's like what
music do you want to play you're dead
and gone and you you're being petty
petty from the Beyond G yeah literally I
remember the music cuz Linda still has
my sweat that's why that's how Petty is
my ex stepmom can go to hell that's
where I'm at uh no did you have anyone
on your list yeah my ex- stepmom oh you
really did yeah okay and then he had his
ex-wife his other ex-wife I wonder if I
wonder if I'm on there or not you
probably are he's been like I need to
plus one I get a plus
one both
Ex-Wives okay so wait we've got a mom
who's passed you've got an ex- stepmom
so let's get into it what's do your
parents split early yeah so they started
getting divorced when I was five or six
and then the divorce lasted for seven
years yeah okay so they were they had a
lot of stuff living together the entire
time no okay just on paper they're
married at this point I mean they're
married but they're fighting they're in
court actively fighting oh they're in
court too yeah it was like they drug us
into court well my dad really didn't my
mom you know she drug us into court but
she was it was a custody battle and then
it was like they had a bunch of land and
they were like doing really well and
then they got divorced for seven years
and then at the end it was like my mom
got everything and my dad had to start
over damn yeah and were you Clos with
your your dad so close still am love to
death yeah he's the best and your mom
were you close with her as well no it
was really like East and West Germany it
was like I love that that's the yeah
it's like my mom and my sister versus me
and my dad and my dad and I were
obviously West you know not the
Hatfields and McCoys or the [__] monu
and the cat it was East and West Germany
that's
aggressive yeah we're West yeah you're
West for sure yeah um no so it is really
uh so did that div did that cause excuse
me did that cause a divide with your mom
because she did you feel like she was
railroading your dad in a way or I was
too young for a lot of it to understand
and then yeah once she was like putting
us on trial to testify against my dad
and like bribing us you actually got
that far you had to go you didn't just
go to court you got on trial well she
tried to and then the guardian at light
and pulled us down cuz they're like
these kids are not it was very clear
that I was being bribed because my mom
was bribing me to like say that my dad
was an alcoholic but I'm like I don't
know what an alcoholic was so I couldn't
even say the word but I was like trying
to say it and they're like we got to
pull her off the stand so yeah it sucked
it was uh it was very acrimonious and
um yeah it d drove a huge wedge between
our family you know my uh my dad finally
just gave up he finally was like okay
whatever he's like as long as I have
partial custody of the kids you can have
everything else and he rebuilt his life
and then good for your dad yeah and then
got married again to another piece of
work that's nice you just say a piece of
work yeah piece of work and then she
took him to the cleaners when they got
divorced so like fo me one shame of you
fool me
twice so wait um you said Mom won so you
have to go live with her like you're too
young to even have a say and like n we
want to go with Dad yeah so even when we
did have a say it didn't didn't matter
because my mom she was undiagnosed
borderline personality and she would
always get the police involved in stuff
like I remember on Father's Day the
night before Father's Day she took my
sister and I to a hotel and was like
feeding us ice cream and like letting us
swim and like doing all the stuff she
would never do and so I remember
thinking something's up
and she brought us back late for
Father's Day my dad was rightfully
Furious
and um he came like flying up the
driveway and she called the police and
she got him arrested on Father's Day on
Father's Day man she set him up she was
yeah she set him up yeah us you guys I
know he just got mad I know that sucks
that this guy just wants to be with his
kids on Father's Day and he's pissed
that he can't be not he's an [__] not
yeah not that he's missing an action on
Father's Day yeah no he just wanted
can't find them Dr he just knew she was
being so manipulative and he knew
exactly what she was doing and I
remember her like grabbing me and being
like he's dangerous run for your lives
and I'm like oh nah you heard [__] like
run for your for your lucky yeah and I
was just like okay and then I had to
watch my dad get
handcuffed on Father's Day Britney is
that's real oh that's he had to sit in a
jail cell on father because he wanted to
be with his kids he's in there with guys
that are probably like [__] my kids I
don't know my kids he's like I want to
be with my kids yeah
but she was like yeah she was that kind
of demon you know she was like very
manipulative can I just switch gears
real quick I want to come back to all
this but I just Martine and I were
talking about this because I saw this
clip recently is that true we can cut
this out if it's not but about your dad
and dmer is that true it is yeah so it
was my dad's best friend's birthday Mike
kakowski and they were at a bar and I
obviously didn't put the whole like oh
yeah Wisconsin oh yeah so the bar across
the street my dad used to go to this bar
called stennies and across the street
from stenes is a place it's now called
Lage it's still a gay bar but it used to
be where dmer would go Troll And if he
didn't have luck there he would go
across the street to steny's and so my
dad was at steny's after his best
friend's wedding and this guy came up to
him and started hitting on him very
aggressive and was like grabbing his ass
and like trying to my dad was like a big
[__] Jack dude he's still pretty big
but he was he was really big when he was
younger and he came up to him and he was
like um I'm going to give you 3 seconds
to get away from me my dad said this and
my dad was like one and then dmer was
like
two damn and on three he [__] knocked
him out laid him out cold and this was
this was in 1991 so this was right
before he was about to get caught and
literally his his friends that were with
him at the bar that night called him
like a few weeks later and they're like
that guy is on TV and it was Jeffrey
[__] dmer so he had already committed
many murders almost all of them holy
[__] your dad could have been next no my
dad would have never there's so many
drugs you know what I mean like I'm just
saying he was a Target but there's just
he said two he said two said said two
I'm like that's the kind of cuz dmer
wasn't bigger than my dad you know my
dad was a big guy so it's like I'm like
this guy was just [__] asking for it
but okay yeah so this poor dude dud is a
rested on Father's Day yeah and now what
happens you guys all go with Mom and are
you in close proximity like can dad
drive over at any point and see you guys
yeah Dad Dad would drive over every
morning when we went down to the bus
stop and he would drive over I know he
was the best dad yeah he was the best
dad he was like 5 minutes away he would
make his coffee would come over and sit
with us at the bus stop in the morning
we'd go to school and then sometimes
that's all you know we would see him we
saw him Tuesday Thursday every other
weekend but when when he didn't have us
he would come over and hang out with us
at the bus stop hell yeah yeah he was
the best can't say nothing about that no
he's the best I mean I would never have
that kind of a DED dedication to a kid
I'd be like you wait at the bus stop
it'll build character you can wait
alone I'm like what man that's nice that
you had that yeah so he was great but it
was really hard because it was like my
dad was awesome so spending time with
him was great and then my mom was you
know she was mentally ill so I don't
want to be like she was crazy or evil or
whatever I know she went through a lot
um but she was really
tough really [__] tough tell me about
her what what was your relationship like
growing up with her it was always hard
because she was really
overprotective and she wouldn't let us
like go out hang out with friends we
couldn't go to school dances we couldn't
watch TV we couldn't yeah we like missed
the world I think she was trying so hard
to protect us from like the evil of the
world that we really saw nothing and
then once I did start getting out of the
house I felt like I had a lot to make up
for so I was like moving real fast you
know what I mean I was like if I would
have maybe just developed at a regular
Pace with all my other friends in terms
of dating and that kind of stuff I maybe
would not have been such a hoe but
like I want expect you to say that I was
such a hoe like right when I got out of
the house I was like I have to make up
what age do you lose your virginity 15
that's respectable age I feel like of
most kids I the second I could get out
of the house oh that's the first time oh
really oh you weren't out at like 13 and
wait that was no I wasn't denying
opportunities I was did you just
cartwheel out that front
[__] put it in I was like yeah you
know one of these idiots from the high
school football team okay and then it
was on from there like it on is that I
and I'm not I don't we don't need to get
into your sexual life either but you can
talk about whatever you want but also
it's on like do you start partying are
you drinking are you okay so everything
you're going for at this point yeah it
was like you know when I was growing up
my mom was really tough and by that I
mean like verbally abusive and and just
like very tough and then school was
really hard I had I was bullied in
school a lot why so
um here's the thing you know that thing
like when you're an adult I think this
is like it also pertains to but like
when you really want something it can
feel that and it doesn't want you back
like I really wanted friends so I was
like trying too hard to get friends and
they were like you're [__] weird but
like I really just wanted to be a part
of something I really wanted to be
accepted I really wanted to have a click
I really wanted but like it's hard to
make friends with somebody who can't
leave the house yeah and can't go play
it with you anywhere I can't go do
anything schoolmates yeah so um you're
just dying to meet a friend yeah I just
wanted somebody and then yeah once I
found alcohol I was like oh I've arrived
guess what I'm like guess what [__] you
I was like oh I don't need friends but
that's the crazy thing is the second I
started drinking I was like all of you
yeah I'm like all of you guys can suck
my [__]
dick I got so many friends like people
just started coming to me they're like
what happened to you like why do you all
of a sudden like yourself I'm like well
thank you bicardi Raz you know is that
what it was confidence brought to you by
bardi yeah yeah and then what your
relationship with mom stays does it ever
get better no uh unfortunately no um so
yeah she it was really tough in in high
school and then she um when I was 16 in
the state of Wisconsin you can decide
which parent you want to go live with 16
so I said I told my dad I want to go
move with you and she was going to get
the police involved like she's going to
get the cops involved saying that he's
letting me drink he's doing all these
things he's a negligent parent so my dad
was like please don't like just stick it
out he's like it's two more years and I
was like okay fine so um I did that and
then on my 18th birthday I came home
from school and all there was a bunch of
boxes on the front porch and a note on
those boxes it was all my stuff and a
note on those boxes saying if you ever
step foot on my property again it will
be trespassing and I will call the
police your mom my mom so I pack all my
things a hold on so using you for
leverage the entire time against your
father and the moment you're a [__]
adult it's like get the [__] out of here
because I have no use for you anymore
it's not even that it's like she's
borderline personality disorder so one
of their things is like they're very
afraid of Abandonment so they will try
and leave people first and so the day I
turned 18 she knew legally she didn't
have a foot to keep me where I was so
she wanted to get rid of me before I
could reject her and leave and move out
which I would have done but but you know
I don't know that I would have cuz it
was like my birthday was in April and
then you know you graduate in what is it
may or whatever and then I was going to
college so I was I don't know what I
would have done but anyway I go to my
dad's house I'm so excited I was like
I'm moving in this is great and he's
like we have to go to the bank and I was
like what she was the custodian on my
college account and I was supposed to go
to ASU and he's like we have to go to
the bank to get your college oh my god
of course you picked ASU oh yeah of
course you picked number one or two
party school in the unit States yeah
number it's like that in Florida State
or like wiconsin actually was there too
it was a big one when I was in college
which was a long time ago so we go to
the bank and I'm pleading with the
teller I'm like I need this money I have
to give ASU a deposit she's like what
and I was like I'm going to college it's
my college fund and she was like honey
there's $16 in this account no how much
was supposed to be in there
uh a lot it's all gone it's all gone she
took it and enough for me me to pay for
college and it was
gone and and who had been putting that
in there for you me it was so that's not
even your dad that's your own money save
so she forced me into like childhood
modeling when I was younger so it was
like all the money from that all the
money I had been getting from relatives
throughout the years like for birthdays
everything it was my account it was my
money it was what I was supposed to
launch me and I just started crying and
my dad just started laughing and he's
like she [__] got
you he's like she got yeah he's like I
knew she was going to do this and he
just looked at me he was kind of crying
but he was more laughing cuz he was like
I [__] knew it he's like this is what
she did to me when we got divorced she
moved all the money
around and I was like okay so thank God
it was such a blessing and disguise that
I didn't go to ask you yeah I agree you
might be dead be you'd be dead you'd be
dead real quick did you confront your
mom about this did you like go right
over there no no there was no it was
done we were not talking there there was
no conversation to be had I remember I
told a few members how how do you do
that honestly how do you not drive right
over to that [__] house F car through
her living room but I mean just verbally
let [__] loose because I knew how
sick she was and I knew that there was
no way she was even going to admit she
did it because the time that I did try
and confront her she denied it when I
told her family members what she did
they all like were like this is between
you and your mom like your mom's saying
she didn't do this so realized I had no
support from anyone and I kind of was
like you know what [__] you I'll just do
it on my
own well go for you yeah I mean sounds
like you're your dad's daughter uh and
you guys got [__] by your mom so he's
like this is how you do it okay so you
go there but now when does stepmom come
into oh she's been in she's she's in uh
and you already know her and things are
not great with her yeah she came in when
I was 10 okay and and now you're 18 and
she was just like this bobblehead drunk
like just does she have kids no okay
just a real bad temper and a drinking
problem and it only got worse it was
like I see why my dad was attracted to
her cuz she was fun but
like she got very angry like she would
slam the doors my dad would have to take
all the doors off the hinges in the
house so she didn't break them just yeah
so she couldn't slam him cuz her thing
was she would get drunk and slam the
doors cuz she would get mad just gang G
not just one done
just like literally I remember the first
time you know what's so funny I was
telling Brandy my move like I used to
argue with my ex and she would kick me
out she'd be like you're getting the
[__] out of here like don't make me
drive all the way home it's late at
night I got to work tomorrow get the
[__] out of here and I would just get up
and then she'd always slam the door but
my move was I'd just leave the front
door open oh yeah just walk out leave it
up make her get up and shut it he that
door I'm make you want to slam it you
[__] slam that was my move was no
slam that's pretty funny yeah I remember
the first time my ex my ex-husband came
home all the doors in the house were off
the hinges and he's like why are the
doors off the hinges and I was like
because Lan is too like
it's oh he was just visiting and saw
that [__] and I was like Dad could you
please put the doors back on like you
couldn't have one door anywhere bathroom
doors are off or should just get it and
go that's so funny that's that's a funny
move you put the doors back on I take a
[__] D could I get a door we're going to
put curtains up we're going to put
curtains up yeah that's too fun so you
guys buttthe heads over the eight years
and now you're going to move in is she
stoked or is she not about this well I
had been half living there the whole
time she was not stoked about the fact I
was alive for all of it she a lot she
really ated my existence
completely I have a video I'll show you
later of like the her grand finale which
is like when the the marriage fell apart
we were home for it was my grandma died
on the oneyear anniversary of my mom's
death they died on the same day wait
your grandma died her own mom yes they
died a year apart on the an same day get
the [__] out of here what are the odds
of that yeah so we are home from my
grandma's funeral everyone is very your
mom just I mean a year is nothing
nothing when you lose someone like that
yes yeah so we're all at the funeral sad
as [__] and we get home and she'd been
drinking jug wine and she was just ready
to fight and we got home we're all so
tired and she just starts going in at us
and she was so drunk she didn't notice I
was filming so I'll show you she really
went she's like you Britney you can go
to hell it's like she's like [__] you I
think my mom and my grandma might have
just done that okay that's where we're
coming back from God damn it yeah I was
like I'm Already
There moment I walked in here through a
doorless house
okay moment I breezed in here he just
has to Rob one the block right
there that is too much oh my God oh my
God your mom your grandom died on the
anniversary the one year that sounds
like some heartbreak [__] that's yeah
you ever brush your teeth forget and
then take a big Swig of orange juice if
you have then you know that some things
just don't mix I hated that as a kid
like oil and water right our bodies
don't absorb CBD oil well so when you
reach for oilbased CBD products you
could be absorbing as low as 6% of
what's on the label next Evo Naturals
developed a proprietary water soluble
form of CBD clinically tested multiple
times which has proven to work faster
and absorb four times better so you can
stay calmer or sleep better during this
stressful time of year I'm going to tell
you right now I take it I love CBD and
uh I've been less stressed I'm
definitely sleeping better I feel more
focused all right and there with so many
choices you can trust the brand with
data next Evo products are proven to
absorb four times better than most
oil-based products and they work fast
now you can try their brand new Extra
Strength daily Wellness CBD gummies that
are two times stronger than regular
strength don't waste your time with
oilbased CBD that might not work upgrade
to better natural solutions from next
Evo go to next evo.com and use promo
code honeydew to get 25% off that's 25%
off at
neo.com promo code honeydew this podcast
is sponsored by better help this time of
year can be a lot and it's natural to
feel some sadness or anxiety about it
adding something new and positive like
therapy to your life can help counteract
some of those feelings I know a lot of
you out there worry about money and
getting kids Christmas gifts and you
know working and all juggling schedules
travel all of it I get it all right it
can make you feel grounded and give you
the tools to manage everything going on
all right you know I'm a big believer in
therapy big believer in mental health I
believe you got to work out that mind as
much as everybody wants to work their
body and especially now during these
times when it's darker earlier and it's
colder and everything going on if you
really feel like you need help get some
help and if you're thinking of starting
therapy give better help a try it's
entirely online it's designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule you just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get match with the
licensed therapist and you can switch
therapist anytime for no additional
charge find your bright spot this season
with betterhelp visit betterhelp.com
honeydew today to get 10% off your first
month that's betterhelp
hp.com honeydo now let's get back to the
de man okay so your mom what happens to
your mom how old is she when she passes
and why so yeah my mom um let's fast so
we my mom and I we don't have to fast
forward go back to doors off the hinges
if you want doors off the hinges so my
mom and I'm going to go back to college
when I'm like at this Crossroad where do
you end up going I went to W Milwaukee
for the first semester because it was so
late I couldn't get in anywhere else and
they were going to give me a free ride I
also had no money free ride from W
Milwaukee is not impressive by the way
and so I went there and then my mom
found out I was going there and she
[__] lost it cuz she's like that does
not she always needed us to look like we
were doing great like what the [__] she
stealing the ASU money for right so she
was like this does not this pedigree
does not align with my parenting you
know what I mean she always thought it
would make her look like a better parent
if you know my sister went to Wisconsin
so she does some black devil magic where
she [__] gets me I I was accepted to
Marquette in the fall and I didn't go
there because I didn't have the money
and she did some something I don't know
what she did where she got me accepted
for the spring
semester on some sort of
Grant I think she might have lied and
said that she was dying because when we
went into the office she was like if
anyone asks you I'm terminally
ill the second I just said that all loud
I'm like I wonder if I'm going to get in
trouble for that but yeah
yeah she's like I'm
Dy I'm dying also I don't know that even
if I had that information if I would say
even in this show right now if you were
I like are you terminally ill you know
be like so you're terminally ill so
you're terminally ill yeah AR right kids
yeah she's terally
well it turns out she was it was just
terminally mentally ill oh okay okay
yeah no so she gets me into Marquette I
went to Marquette and then we had a few
good times at Marquette you know she we
you know she tried to be in my life and
then she just was she was just too much
you know she was always just doing too
much she was always telling me I was an
alcoholic just like my dad and I was
going to be you know was she not a
drinker or anything she drank but she
didn't have a drinking problem but she's
like you're an alcoholic just like your
dad you're going to throw your life away
and when you're an an alcoholic and
you're in the middle of enjoying being
an alcoholic it's not what you want to
hear you know what I mean you ain't
listening anyone right I was like I'm
having a [__] blast just a belch in
the face right there yeah so I didn't
want to hear it and I kind of like was
like get the [__] out of my life and I
moved to California and then when I
moved to California I went to go see a
friend for Christmas and I got a DUI at
in Arizona and I had to go to jail for
30 days and did you go to [__] Tent
City I was supposed to but I got a
lawyer and I went to the the Beverly
Hills pay to stay oh out here yeah pay
to stay yeah what's that it's like you
pay to stay there and it's like pretty
nice it's like it's like where the
elites go to ja is it real pay to stay
so it's like like a little Marriott or
something basically a hotel literally
yeah it's literally right off Rodeo
Drive you have your own room Stu yeah
you have your own room you have a TV a
door yeah they
keep yeah you imagine if they lock her
up in there they have to get rid we're
getting rid of doors now like God damn
it no [__] I didn't know that yeah and
that's considered time served as long as
you pay to stay there yeah huh it was
you know I still went to jail but my mom
this was her big moment where she was
like I [__] told you you're an
alcoholic you're going to ruin your life
and I'm like in this moment I need a
mother I need you to be a mom and either
support me or don't talk to me and she
just kept going and I finally said to
her I was like listen if ever you're
ready to get help for for your mental
illness I will be there for you I will
fly home to be in therapy with you I
want to support you but until then I
cannot have a relationship with you like
I love you dearly but this is way too
hard and we were aange from that day
forward I don't remember the last time I
saw my mom but I knew it was getting
worse uh near the end because she
started cutting everyone else out of her
life like for me the longest time it was
just me I had just cut her out and then
it was like other family members started
cutting her out my sister cut her out my
aunts cut her out my grandparents cut
her out everyone was like you need to
stay the [__] away from us and when I
found out everyone had cut her off I was
like this is it here she she's getting
ready to kill herself and I remember
like drunkenly I was trying I was so sad
and I was trying to get a hold of her I
was calling her cell phone calling her
landline trying to email her and she had
changed everything because by the time
it was you know near the end of her life
she was in a full state of schizophrenia
Mania like she was gone she thought
Donald Trump was in her light she
thought people were coming into her
house and stealing her clothes and um
how old was
she I don't even know I think like 54
young yeah and how long had it been
since you guys communicated from the
that last moment to her death so she
died in
2017 um and I think it was about six
years since we had spoken and but I did
I tried to get a hold of her and I
couldn't and I think that was the
universe or whatever kind of standing in
the way because I think if I had gotten
a hold of her you know as long as she
kind of had the life to suck out of
somebody she would it would keep her
alive [__] FR sitting right on she
was like a witch she was just like you
know so
um I I couldn't get a hold of her and
then three days before my wedding I was
supposed two days before my wedding I
was supposed to be leaving to go to
Nicaragua for my wedding ceremony and I
got the call and it was from my aunt and
she said are you driving and I said yep
and she said you need to pull over and I
said who's dead is it Mom or Grandma cuz
my grandma was she had blood cancer and
she's like it's your mom and I was like
how did she do it and she was like how
did you know she killed herself like
well is that really how she did it she
killed herself yeah she shot herself in
the head no I did not think you were
going to say that gang [__] that's
[__] terrible I thought you were
going to say drugs or pill I think she
had tried a bunch of times before with
pills my sister told me that she tried
once on Christmas with pills and I was I
didn't know cuz I wasn't around and my
sister didn't tell me I think my sister
was trying to protect how crazy she was
from me but um she shot herself first of
all did she have a gun she she did okay
so here's the other thing it's like she
was texting people very threatening
messages like she was texting my dad
being like I'm going to [__] kill you
I have a gun watch out and I remember my
ex- stepmom called the police and was
like we're getting death threats and the
cops came over and it was like the most
Wisconsin interaction C ever where
they're like you afraid of a
woman you [__] puss and my dad's like
I didn't call the police he's like I'm
[__] strapped it's like let her try I
ain't afraid of women I'm afraid of this
one right here okay this one I am yeah
but in that moment her gun should have
been taken away from her you know what I
mean but the cop was like this is
outside of my jurisdiction cuz I don't
you know it's like cuz it's Friday night
I need to go for one pepperoni pizza
Papa John that's why yeah so you know
there was a few fumbles but I think
ultimately everything happened the way
it was supposed to she was not going to
find peace here she was a very very
tormented person and who found her so my
she had a boyfriend on and off for 18
years um I call him my stepdad just
because it's easier but they never were
married but she told him that she was
going out of town and that he needed to
watch her dog and
so it's my belief that that when he went
to pick up the dog if he would have went
in the house he would have
noticed her suitcase was there her purse
was there there was a clothes a bag of
clothes to donate and then there was a
bag of clothes on the basement door that
had his name on it so um and then she
was in the
basement so he came to pick up the dog
didn't go in the house just grabbed the
dog and then he didn't hear from her for
a few days so he went back to the house
do you think she'd already done it or do
you know she know because he didn't find
her until like the 19th or 20th I mean
sorry when when he went to get the dog
was she already gone that's yeah I think
she was gone because by the time he
finally went in and found her she killed
herself November 9th and she wasn't
found until the 19th oh wow that's a
long time so yeah she was like late
stage deom and I don't think that was
her plan I think it was her plan to be
found a little more glamorous yeah yeah
man I'm sorry that's rough how do you
feel about that I feel like it was it's
devastating I but I am so much closer
not shocked not shocked I can tell you
weren't shocked you even said how'd she
do it you literally said how'd she do it
shock wasn't an emotion there was a ton
of relief because I also think I had
been drinking at her for so many years
where I was like stuck in this sort of
cycle I've never heard that term before
drinking at someone oh yeah I was really
mad and I was like I'll show you an
alcohol like you think I'm an alcohol
[__] can show you an alcoholic and so
the first thing I felt was relief both
for her because I knew that she would be
able to be at peace now and then also
for myself because I'm like I can stop
drinking I don't have to keep doing this
yeah you did yeah I've been sober since
the day after her funeral wow right like
just like that how long have you been
drinking since I was 15 wow yeah so 15
to 28 and you just stop like that yeah
that's great it wasn't easy but I did
stop all of a [__] reason but it is
it is good that you did that's oh man
yeah and what is what was your dad's
take on that oh my dad was devastated on
the on her death devastated so we did go
to Nicaragua to do the our like did they
remain friendly at all no okay she was
my belief is that she still loved him
very much but she didn't know how to
express love she was a very violent
lover you know so she would Express Love
by saying this is what you're doing
wrong with your life this is what you
need to fix and it's really interesting
because in hindsight I always just
thought my mom was like this venomous
[__] and like now that she's gone and
there's been some space I'm like
everything she said was right yeah it
was just the way she delivered it it's
like that I was an alcoholic is a big
one it's a big one or like when I got
tattoos you know I started getting
tattoos and she's like you're G to
you're GNA by the time you're 30 you're
going to be removing those I'm in the
middle of removing them right now like
and I was just like [__]
you but yeah no she everything
everything she said was right she also
just like really believed in me and I
think I didn't see it cuz cuz she was so
mean but she was like anything you want
to do with your life you can do she's
like you just have to stop drinking and
I was like that's an attack because I
didn't want to stop drinking so it's
like I kind of dedicate my sobriety to
her because I'm like turns out she was
right and then you get married how long
after that oh the original question was
how how does my dad that's right I'm
sorry thank for bringing us back yeah
cuz you said they didn't remain close
and
no she was like very like she always
biger towards him she 100% still loved
him but um so we go to Nicaragua to have
this wedding ceremony it's very small
it's like me and my closest friends my
ex-husband his parents um my dad and
stepmom at the time and then my sister
and her husband and um my dad was the
most sad of anyone he was it was just
like this deep
dark unshakable sadness and my ex
stepmom was pissed I was going to ask
she was pissed she's like I [__] knew
you still loved her she's dead right now
she's dead she said but then the best
part was like on the reception night my
stepmom was trying to frog her across
some stools to come say to come say
something to me and the stool kicked out
from under her and she hit her head on a
rock and I was like we thought she was
gone like her eyes were rolling back in
her head she looked like force Whitaker
at the optometrist she was just
like
yeah so we thought she was going to die
too but but no she was pissed she was
pissed at my dad and my dad was really
really [__] sad but it's like of
course he is the the mother of his
children yeah I mean it's also someone's
lost a life she's been sick for a long
time this is the lady I had kids with
yeah it's yeah it was sad but yeah so we
we got married we had our little wedding
ceremony it was surprisingly amazing it
was really fun I knew I was going to
quit drinking after that so I had like a
full send like my gay friends brought
Molly we what do you mean you knew you
were going to stop drinking after that
you just you drank for your wedding yeah
I see and then I knew shortly after my
mom's funeral it was like G to be done
so um we found some like Nicaraguan
cocaine [__] did Molly I drank a ton
it was so much fun it was like the best
weekend ever that's your wedding but I'm
just like yeah but that was the end you
know and then sobriety was really tough
work what's the hardest part which your
best friend for me alcohol was my best
friend was it was the alcohol that it
got me through everything gave me
confidence it's I literally thought who
I was was who I was when I was drinking
that was my identity does that make
sense like I was like I'm this confident
sexy bad [__] and then I got sober and
I just started crying a lot and I was
like who the [__] is this
person loose [__] Lo I'm crying in
the [__] freezer section at the G
like you [__] [__] yeah [__] no
but they
say they say in sobriety when you are
drinking and using it's like throwing
everything in the back of a station
wagon and then when you get like all
your problems then when you get sober
it's like slamming on the brakes
everything comes forward slams forward
that's a great that's a great analogy
yeah that does make sense just [__]
coming everywhere I didn't even know we
had a tennis racket just hit me in the
face so [__] sad I was like I didn't
even identify as depressed right now I
am suicidal so you feel like that made
marriage difficult or just life in
general or both I think I really give my
ex-husband a lot of props for staying
with me through that you together we
literally had just gotten married and
then I got sober and I was a nightmare
for the first how long were you
married six months oh so we I we got
married in LA in February at the
courthouse and then our ceremony or our
like party in Nicaragua was in November
so I got sober
December 11th of 2017 but we had
technically been married since February
got it but still early and I became a
completely different person like he
married this happy go-lucky party girl
and then all of a sudden I was just like
crying and ready to [__] die for like
four months and he was an angel he was
it's so hard to watch somebody you love
go through that range of emotions and
feel those big feelings and you know
it's such a helpless feeling when
somebody you love is suffering and like
we've reversed roles like there was
times when he was suffering and I was
witnessing but I think just to for him
to hold space and not judge me and let
me kind of have
that moment of growth was I would
imagine very challenging but but I'm
really grateful that he did that for me
so how do you come to 6 months and say
all right we're going to stop this stop
what the marriage marriage wait we
didn't stop the marriage that's what I'm
saying how long were you actually
married completely together yeah so
February to what's February to December
nine months n months yeah 10 months yeah
but we didn't stop it I I got sober we
didn't stop the marriage you're divorced
now right that's what I'm saying okay
sorry I I see what we're arriving we're
arriving at the divorce the overall
window but how long were you guys
together we were okay sorry we were
married for 5 years together for seven
and the first months you're saying was
BR got it all right but then you do make
it past that that's why I thought you
were like no we called it at 6 months
okay I'm sorry I'm sorry I misunderstood
yeah yeah no we made it past that and
then like he had his moments and I Had
My Moments he ended up getting sober oh
he was an alcoholic as well he just well
he doesn't he won't identify as an
alcoholic but he's not drank for four
years and his life is exponentially
better than it ever was before so is
yours 100% good it's it's night and day
like I look at pictures of myself when I
used to drink and I'm like I look 10
years older than I do today is that
right you really look at a picture and
like I look older than today oh yeah I
was showing my friend a picture of me in
high school or in college the other day
cuz this basketball player that I used
to love got engaged and I was pissed and
she's like wait show me a picture of you
guys and and I'm telling you I look can
I just show you right now yeah hang on a
second she was like and this is how long
ago I'm about to see this is in
this is in college so like my sophomore
year of college
maybe oh yeah you yeah holy [__] you do
look way better no offense she's like
you look atrocious in that picture I'm
like thank you I can't even yeah wow
that's from the drinking you say you
think that's like what ALC like bloat
yeah alcohol blood yeah damn yeah I mean
you don't look bad but there's and
that's how many years ago yeah 15 15
damn yeah wow so alcohol's looks good
out of you yeah yeah if nothing for
vanity I will stay sober so then what
happens in the
marriage yeah
um why do you end up splitting after
five
years are you don't have to talk about
this no no no it's okay it was it was a
lot of things I think when I was in the
marriage I felt very suffocated and I
felt like you know comedy's a tricky gig
and it felt like I was swimming against
a current at home like he wanted to um
he wanted me to be successful but like
he also kind of didn't you know what I
mean he kind of there kind of felt like
there was resistance and I just felt
suffocated and there was a big both of
us were very codependent so I had like
completely forgotten who I was without
him and I didn't like that I was like I
want to figure out who I am again and I
think I think too like now that I've
been out of the marriage for a year I
think when I left him I very much was
like I need to figure myself out I need
space I need this I need that now that
I've been out of the marriage and done
like a lot of work on myself I think a
lot of it has to do with the fact that
like I was raised in such a tumultuous
environment and my mom was so chaotic so
I often times think that love is chaos
and the marriage was very peaceful and I
didn't trust it and I I think on a core
level don't think I thought I was worthy
of love and so I tried to blow it up a
million different ways in the beginning
and it didn't work cuz he just loved me
and he was just there for me and then
ultimately I I blew it up and I walked
away because I just think I didn't think
I I deserved that love or that happiness
and I think that that sucks to realize
once you're gone you know what I mean
but um I did have to leave in order to
even do this work to see that that was a
problem because I'm like I don't want to
go go through life being in
relationships even if they're healthy
where I think on some core level I'm
unlovable and then I just keep trying to
test them and blow them up because
that's just hell you
know
so the reason I left when I left and the
reason I left now are different do you
know what I mean I do yeah I thought it
was one thing but I realized it was
something else and it's me it's not him
like that's the thing it's 50/50 but is
there a chance you two would ever get
back together again
um he has had another girlfriend since
October of last year so he's been in a
relationship for a year now um and I
love him deeply and we are very good
friends and I oh you are very good
friends okay so you communicate oh yeah
we still co-parent our dog oh okay and
um he's still one of my best friends he
can make me laugh like no one else but
um I think I need to continue to do the
work on myself and figure out like how
to love myself because I don't like I
went in as a broken machine and I think
alcohol was like I didn't know who I was
when I was drinking and alcohol in the
beginning was like getting sober and
going through that whole change was like
really big for me and I think the change
I'm going through now is also very big
so it's like I need to do more work on
myself before I even entertain any
relationship because when I got when I
became single I started dating right
away again and it was a [__] disaster
like it was was so bad because I just
was used to being like in this
codependent relationship and I was used
to like needing somebody to validate
myself and I realized I was like getting
high off people and like there was just
like a ton of stuff that like made it
very uncomfortable so I'm like before I
get into another relationship I have a
lot of work I need to do on myself and I
asked you outside if you thought you
would or is that the last marriage and
you said I don't want to ever Say Never
And I agree with that so you're you are
open to it
if% I want partnership I want to be in a
relationship but you know I also want it
to be mutually uplifting and I don't
want it to be a ton of I think when we
got into that relationship both of us
had a ton of work we had to do and it
felt like I was working on him and then
I was working on myself and it just was
so much work where it's like I feel like
that's why I'm saying I need to like
work on myself before I get into another
relationship
because I don't want to go into another
relationship broken and being like fix
me are you my daddy you know what I mean
like have that kind of that needy energy
people can feel that um how's your dad
been through all this he's been through
separations he was incredible like when
I first started feeling like I wanted a
divorce I was talking to him a lot and
he was like listen like you know what
you need he's like I'm not going to say
anything about Chris he's like I love
Chris he's a fantastic man he's like but
I will say being alone is better than
being with the wrong person you know and
I don't think Chris was necessarily the
wrong person but I do agree that like I
I needed the space and um my dad is like
on the other side of his second divorce
and he's the happiest he's ever been
that's what I want to ask you so what
happened with um ex- stepmom why so that
night finally oh that night did fight
night it was fight night he finally said
that's enough he yeah it was like you
know I think that sort of crazy fighting
had been hiding in the shadows and we
hadn't seen it but she brought it all
out for the world oh you that's the
first time you'd seen that I had seen it
because she did it to me behind closed
doors and then I would say to my dad I'm
like she's doing this and he's like she
does that she'll corner you and then
like she'll get you in a place where you
know it's your word versus hers and
nobody's going to believe you if you are
saying she's saying this crazy [__]
about you so um yeah it was fight night
and we had to leave the house and she
got a knife and she tried to stab him
get the [__] out of here mhm and he had
to take it out of her hand this is your
mom's funeral my grandma's funeral
grandma's funeral the year later also my
stepmom's also her funeral at a at the
wake or whatever no we're back at my
dad's house she grabbed a knife then
after you all left when we all left yeah
no when we left the house we had to
leave the house because she was going
[__] crazy she was taking swings at
me this is the recording you yeah she
was taking swings at me swings oh yeah
my ex-husband had to get in the way
there was a point where she like flicked
his hat off it was just she was just
getting nasty so we had to leave and
when we left she grabbed a knife and
tried to stab my dad and then she didn't
remember anything like not a thing no so
when he's like we're I'm done she's like
I don't remember it yeah which if that's
true that's really dark because it was
like two hours it was like 2 hours long
of
like insane rage and just trying to
[__] kill
me were you close with your grandom who
passed yeah I loved her very much she
was the best what happened literally
what happened to her oh she had um blood
cancer so she was sick for years mom
grandma Yeah so she was sick and we knew
she didn't have much longer and then I
think the Heartbreak on top of I was
going to say she's got blood cancer and
then she just buries her own kid was she
able to make it out to the funeral and
stuff yeah yeah yeah I remember when we
were putting my mom's n in the Crypt I
guess it is my grandma was like I'm next
and I was like what she's like it's
either me or Danny which is her her son
and I was either me or Dan Danny parties
Danny had a brain aneurism on my 10th
birthday so we're all surprised Danny
still kicking it okay but he's a man
that's I remember uh my father died when
I was 16 and my grandmother that's her
son you know she had a barrier son and
my grandfather had died like he died the
year I'm born like 73 so he's already
got the name and the a start and
expiration date on there my
grandmother's over here with the
beginning in the TBD you know but then
my father surprisingly dies so what they
end up doing is burying my father I
think they were he was like 10 ft down
and she's six they stack them right
which i' had never heard of this until
this and I'm like what so my
grandmothers I mean I you know when
you're a kid it's also like look that's
my dad and now that I'm a parent I'm
like I [__] I wouldn't care how old
my kid was I'd be yelling at their kids
too like you shut the [__] up and um
she's just going nuts and she's she's
just saying I'm going to be buried on
top of my son so we go back to the house
I'm just like how are you doing she's
like kind tell you something I'm like
yeah she goes you want to know something
that was really freaking me out and I go
by the way when she saw my father laid
out in the coffin my grandmother grabbed
that coffin and shook it so hard she
almost brought the whole thing down that
the people had to go get her you know
we're like oh my God and she said
staring at that [__] empty space
where her death date's going to be
that's what she was after her son's in
there she just looking like I'm next
yeah I'm [__] next is that crazy it
is crazy yeah
we used to have a family death pool like
who's going to die first yeah we had so
many people dying left and right we
would do a family Deathpool and now I
talk to my cousins and stuff I'm like
yeah we're we're on Deck you know I mean
you could start betting on us now yeah
you know what I mean damn it's dark so
you and your dad now he's he's loving
life you're both divorcees at the same
time are you hanging out and getting
together yeah I've spent more time with
my dad in the last year than I have
since I moved to California I'm
especially with like you know the tour
my schedule is whatever I want it to be
and I don't have anything tethering me
to La so I've been home like six times
this year we're just hanging out he's
still in Wisconsin yeah we're just
chilling I love it good for you I'm very
happy for you thank you you look healthy
thank you yeah yeah um all right now I'm
going to ask you it's your first time
here I ask everybody their first time
after everything we've talked about
advice you would give to 16-year-old
Britney
probably that it's everything is going
to be okay and also maybe don't [__] so
many
guys you're getting ready you're getting
ready to
[__] maybe just like a few of them a lot
was it a lot you're saying it's a lot a
lot yeah like the high school like you
well High School yeah I pillaged I
pillaged they your own did you go to
rival schools no I went to rival schools
I didn't sleep with anyone in my high
school except for the guy I lost my
virginity to and then it was all rival
schools and then the guys in my school
got mad that I wasn't I wasn't [__]
them so they started a Facebook hate
group against me called the classic
eight [__] CES they Facebook at your
time in school it had just I was like
probably the first group first shame
group on Facebook it's you
yeah and it was just a bunch of guys
that wanted to [__] me who couldn't like
just talking [__] just talking mad [__]
and I was like sick yeah no no High
School sure whatever that was fun
college is where we really start
talk about burying bodies Marquette yeah
yeah all right I'm basketball team I was
the sixth
man um thank you for doing this I really
appreciate you coming on please plug and
promote everything one more time yeah my
website is Britney schmit.com and then
you can find me at Britney Schmid on
Instagram and Tik Tok I'm on tour for
five more weeks then I'm [__]
retiring all right so tired I know I'm
going to take off
once I shoot this thing it's I need to
take off yeah uh as always ryan.com Ryan
sickler on all social media we'll talk
to youall next
[Music]
[Applause]
week